Warning.
This video is about profanity across
cultures,
so profanity is used uncensored.
You were discretion
is advised.
[inaudible]
where do bad words come from and what
are the similarities,
if any,
across languages and cultures in
swearing?
What causes some words to be worse than
others?
These questions have fascinated
linguists for centuries and today we're
going to look at some of the answers.
When you look across the world,
profanity is almost a universal feature
of language.
We have created thousands of different
profane words,
but despite some moderate variation
between languages,
the types of words we classify as
unsayable in public share.
A lot of overlap and this is because we
all create bad words around social
taboos.
Taboos are things in a society that are
considered to private,
gross,
ugly or sacred.
Their topics so delicate that they can
only be allowed in certain places.
Bodily functions,
for example,
have taboos that are confined to the
bathroom.
Sex has taboos that are confined to the
bedroom,
uncomfortable past events contained
taboos that are confined to history,
class and religious rituals have taboos
that are confined to the temple or
church and these taboos.
Sometimes though not always will lead to
certain words describing them becoming
themselves off limits due to the
association with the taboo itself.
In other words,
not only do we have a contextual
allowance for sensitive parts of our
lives,
we do the same with the words describing
them.
For example,
you can say poop or but just fine,
but if you talk about shit or an ass,
well now you've crossed the line even
though they are words for the same
thing.
One has been deemed culturally
appropriate and the other has not.
Now,
some cultures create different taboos
and others,
but looking across the world,
we generally find the same big four
taboos,
creating most of the bad language,
the four horsemen of profanity,
sex,
bodily function,
religion and slurs and this pattern of
fairly common taboos,
breeding similar bad words because
Benjamin k Bergen in his book,
what the F to come up with a
categorization method for profanity that
he calls the holy fucking Shit nigger
principle.
Yeah,
that's actually what he calls it.
Here's the idea.
Benjamin Bergen says that nearly all so
called bad or forbidden words fall into
one or more of the following types of
profanity.
Holy meaning religious or sacred Glass
Homie,
fucking meaning relating to sex shit
relating to bodily functions.
And finally nigger relating to slurs
towards groups.
Any nasty pejorative to describe groups
of people fall here.
Now of course some bad words like slut
might fall into multiple categories.
It's both a slur about a group and also
a word about sex.
So bear in mind that bad words can fall
into multiple camps.
As a quick note from here out,
as we discuss this principal,
I'll be referring to it as the h f s in
principle.
This is because one,
it's a mouthful and two,
it's safe way to start the conversation
without requiring a disclaimer at the
beginning of your discussion.
So now that we have that out of the way,
besides being disconcertingly memorable,
why did Benjamin Bergen find the hfs in
principles so useful?
The answer is because it does a great
job to categorize most swearing and
profanity by the human taboo.
They draw power from,
and this is valuable because while all
our words differ,
the things we described are the same.
So it's reasonable to suggest that
studying the roots of profanity will
reveal something about the profanity
itself.
And the first thing you find is that
taboos are definitely tendencies and
culture,
but you also find that they are not
guaranteed to take ruth and the taboos
that had culture does.
Carrie tells you something about their
history.
For example,
some languages like Cantonese,
Chinese that come from more secular
cultures,
perhaps unsurprisingly don't possess
Coley profanity in their lexicon.
They do,
however,
have some swear words about their
ancestors due to their history of
ancestor reverence.
But that's not all.
When we look at the top five words that
are considered most defensive in Chinese
known as the outstanding five,
all of them have to do with sex.
So we can safely say that Chinese is not
a holy language,
instead primarily a fucking language,
but other languages like Quebecois
French can be considered holy languages
because of their deep Catholic roots.
They're profane.
Dictionary has what are called Saccos,
literally meaning consecrations,
which are Catholic liturgical terms like
sacrament that when uttered in the right
context are seen as some of their
strongest swear words.
Deb Neck for example,
is stronger than their word for fuck or
shit.
So we can say that,
wow,
Quebecois French has F and s words.
It's more of a holy language than
anything else.
Moving on.
You can also add English to the list of
holy languages coming from a Judeo
Christian religious tradition where it's
like damn or hell.
Obviously our references to religious
ideas and English is an interesting
swearing language in general in that we
are an h f s and in language.
And a good example of the second lesson
we learned from the hfs in principle
within the same culture,
the relative strength of taboos usually
correlates to the relative strength of
the profanity.
So in America for example,
both sex and the scatological are
considered taboo,
but of the two of them sexist,
more taboo hints,
fuck and is related.
Cousins are considered more offensive
than shit or ass and all of the taboo
strengths very heavily by culture.
In German,
for example,
this situation is totally reversed.
German is primarily a shit language.
The German word for fuck Israeli used in
swearing instead,
some variant of shit or ass is used
constantly such as the German word for
asshole phase,
born from an ass shit head.
You get the idea.
Now last but not least,
are there similar languages?
Well,
up until recently,
those slurs have been common across many
cultures.
A general taboo around slurs hasn't been
present.
What I mean by this is those slurs were
used for nefarious purposes and to
promote tribalism and ingroup behavior.
They were not considered taboo by the
culture itself,
but in the last century,
there's a very good argument to make
that in America at least slurs have
quickly become the most universally
powerful taboo we have,
and a good question might be why.
Why did we shift and why are some slurs
seen as worse than others?
Let me suggest one possible explanation.
The civil rights movement in America did
more than change laws.
They highlighted a history of
disenfranchisement amongst certain
groups,
which none of us really want to think or
talk about.
In other words,
this unseemly part of American history
became taboo.
And what happens when we have a powerful
cultural taboo?
Well,
the words that called back to that
uncomfortable history in an
inappropriate way become forbidden.
And once you see that slurs became
powerful when connected with their
historical context,
it's easy to see why in America the
inward is way,
way,
way more offensive to most people.
Then even words like fuck.
Whereas if you visit a culture without
the history of slavery,
they wouldn't find that word is
offensive because the word isn't linked
to the history.
What's up my Nigga?
What did you just say?
Okay,
so now that we've talked about the age,
the FDS and the n in hfs in principle,
now let's spend some time talking about
a few exceptions to these roles that we
find scattered across cultures.
Interesting.
Cultural variance include profane
language about animals.
In Korea,
for example,
calling someone a dog is deeply
offensive.
There's also profanity around disease.
In Dutch,
Profane language includes words for
cancer,
typhoid,
tuberculosis.
Often the severity of the disease
emphasizes the strength of the
profanity.
And a final interesting taboo that pops
up sometimes is a taboo around death and
death related words.
For example,
in some Australian aboriginal cultures
you can't say the name of someone who
has died for up to a year or in more
extreme instances like with the
[inaudible] tribe of Columbia.
This same rule is enforced under the
penalty of death.
However,
even though are local taboos which buck
the trend,
most of the time when you find stable
profane language it tends to follow the
h f s and if you can look past the
offensive charged words we can't say and
instead examine the taboos themselves,
we learn what is actually going on.
It isn't the words themselves,
it's the parts of our life that they're
connected to the parts that our society
is uncomfortable with.
Yeah.
Yup.
Thank you for watching.
This is the first of a two part series
on profanity,
both of which will probably be
demonetized by youtube.
So if you enjoyed this video,
consider supporting me on Patrion and a
big thank you to the patrons who make
long research intensive videos like this
possible.
Even when the topics aren't advertiser
friendly.
Mecca 83 provided both of the songs for
this video,
so if you like the tracks,
you can support them on soundcloud or
spotify links below.
Lastly,
if you want to know more about this
fascinating subject,
further reading and listening
suggestions can be found in the
footnotes.
I'll see you in part two.